good morning guys finally the video
that i have been promising you guys for
a very long time
is now here i am finally gonna show you
guys my animal crossing island
[Music]
i am really nervous i don't know why i'm
so nervous to show you guys this
it's a silly simple game but i have been
obsessed with this game since the
beginning of quarantine and
i blame nikki she totally got me
addicted to it
so the reason why i've been really
nervous to show you guys my island is
because if you don't know anything about
the game
it's just you end up getting this
deserted island and slowly
you build on this island and you're
creating you you're just it's a very
creative type of process
and it's also really tedious because
there's a lot of chores and tests that
you have to do
you have to pay off like your mortgage
and stuff on because you get a house in
the island
all these little things right and so
it's it's a really addictive game
because it requires you to check in
every single day and making sure that
you advance in the game little by little
because everything's like in real time
the time that i
am in like the real world is the same
time that the game is in
so you have to wait like a whole day to
advance like
certain things like for example if i'm
upgrading my house i have to wait an
entire day
i've just been really shy to show my my
my progress so i don't know i've just
been holding it very dear to my heart
for some reason it's not even that
serious i think i've been playing this
game for four months
almost practically every day i've been
playing this game because
they give you like points and stuff like
certain things if you check in every day
so i'm always like oh i can't break my
streak
but recently though this past week i did
not play
for a solid three or four days which has
been the longest time since i started
playing this game that i have not been
playing the game so
we'll see what kind of state my island
is in i did try to clean it up a little
bit before you guys saw it because it's
like oh my gosh it's like
it's like inviting guests into your home
like you want to just make sure
everything's nice and clean and neat so
people aren't judging
but people will judge and it's okay i
just got to be okay with that but
before we get into the island tour i
wanted to give a quick shout out to
babble honey i need you for this part so
casey's been
learning spanish through bad bowl so
shout out to babel once again thank you
guys for partnering up with us we're
we're really excited to be partnering up
with babel and in case you don't know
it is a language learning app and you
gotta tell me all about your language
learning i am not on a streak like you
are on with your animal crossing i've
been not babbling as much as i should be
during this nice break that we are all
involved in right now right but
i am currently working on speaking right
now like learning how to pronounce words
in spanish and stuff and all right here
we go speaking
it says to press and hold while you
speak so i have like they're going to
listen to me
so you guys get to hear my spanish
listen then say it out loud let's listen
to them first
alejandro is alejandro
hey
actually i have youtube credit to like
you you've helped me a lot with
pronunciation it is very
helpful to have someone who knows the
language try to help guide you as you're
doing it but honestly
like with just babble alone i've seen a
great improvement in your spanish
because sometimes we'll try to
speak spanish here and there just
throughout the day and i'm kind of like
quizzing him to see how he's doing
especially on the days that i've noticed
that you're actually using the app
so i really credit babel because you
have been
understanding the language a lot better
than when we have first try to
something true it's like sticking more
right now
ustedes
[Music]
also the way that they're pronouncing in
the app it's just very accurate and
clear but it's not
overly like textbook so the reason why
babel is so
great is because they're actually
teaching you the language as if you're
like conversational
conversationally speaking does that make
sense i gotta work on my english maybe i
should
work on babble's english english yeah so
that's why babble is the number one
language learning app in the world so if
you go
right now to our description click on
the link and that link will get you
50 off a six month subscription to
babel now this is only available for a
limited time i honestly don't know how
long that link is going to be active for
so if you really want to learn a new
language make sure to go down there
right now
click that link get half off your six
month subscription of babble and learn a
new language
and now on to the tour
are you excited i'm nervous
okay your island's beautiful it's cozy
your villagers love you
thank you i i'm a villager i love you
there too
he really is a millionaire she built me
a house i'll explain amazingly i love it
all right thank you have fun see ya
all right welcome to my island
here is the entrance this is frigga say
hi
friega she's so cute she's like she
reminds me of like a
auntie like a grandma or any or
something anyway
right here we have all the gold roses
to the right is able sisters
and then if you go over to the left here
is
nook's cranny that's the shop that's
where you buy things
and stuff and then sell stuff okay oh my
gosh i am so nervous i don't even know
where to go
before we begin here let me show you
guys the map
so this is my map i am very proud of it
and i have spent most of my time playing
this game
in order to just really lay out the
entire map i wanted it to be just very
clean lines i wanted to run across
one side of my eyeline and go all the
way to the other side and then up and
down and then just not have any
obstacles in the way
as you can see it's all practically one
level
and the only like multi-levels that i
have is more towards
you know the top of the map in the
center and up at the very very top the
third
level like the third cliff level it
spells out tick
so and also the name of my island is
tick island and
if you know what tick means and yay but
if you don't it actually means
tiff isaac and casey that's like our
family
thing so like for example a wi-fi in our
home it's
tick manor so we just name everything
tick and also my tesla's name tick
so things like that so that's just to
kind of honor the family there and
that's the reason why i named it
tick island so if you know anything
about this game is the fact that like i
said earlier
every day is when you can advance but
you have to wait like a real life
24 hours in order for your if you don't
time time pop
which i don't i don't do the the time
traveling thing which is where you could
kind of hack the switch
and then move up in the days like just
go to a different time i don't do that
as long as i've been playing this i've
never time traveled
you can tell like how long it took me to
get everything perfect because
every single bridge that is in the
entire island
every single house that i've moved is
just it took a long time and also
because i'm being so
particular and like how like perfect
everything is like there was a lot of
a lot of things that i had to redo
anyway so we're gonna go
counterclockwise
starting from the airport which is down
there where you could see the little
like here
here you are kind of thing i don't know
what i'm doing in this island tour
i have only ever seen two other island
tours one of them was nikki's and the
other one was
pewdiepie's i saw his his island tour
but other than that i haven't seen
any other island tours so i apologize if
this is not what you're used to
but here we go we're gonna go counter
clockwise which is going off to the
right
here right here i set up this little
like
outside able sisters little
tailor shop thing and then i set up some
dresses here i found the designs on
reddit shout outs to
the subreddit where you get all the
animal crossing
stuff like designs because i got this
one too a little surf shop
i have my little surf shop here okay so
one thing to mention
oh and here's like a little music music
area i really like
this area i like to play with like the
guitars and stuff but
one thing to mention is that i have been
trying to
collect absolutely everything that the
game has to offer
if you know anything about this game is
that it's like endless it's like
endless and so all the things also come
in like different colors and different
designs
so i'm just trying to collect them all i
just want everything so that's why
i have like all the all the the wetsuits
here
which is a new thing in the game where
we're able to go out and swim in the
ocean which i have been
absolutely loving there's flick he he
likes to collect or she i think it's a
girl
she likes to collect bugs but right over
here you can see
my house and i did the the moroccan
style kind of spanish tile
on the floor which is kind of what our
real life house is gonna have
with the stenciling of the the concrete
we'll go into the house in a little bit
i'll just show you the rest here so when
it comes to the beach
i don't know what i'm doing ooh
madagascar sunset
moth i gotta get or butterfly or
whatever i forget what it's called but
this one's worth a lot of money hold on
one second
madagascar sunset ma yeah
anyway so when it comes to the beach i'm
just really like listen
i don't know i'm just trying to throw
things into the design somehow just so i
could use up the things i've collected
and anything that i have doubles of i'll
give to my villagers or
i'll just sell but here i have a little
tiki bar this is one of the first things
that i created
the tiki bar look at spongebob and
patrick isn't this cute
i love that okay so then more beach time
over here
beach stuff like oh yeah let's have fun
with the beach but
wait come on there we go beach ball and
then right here's a pier
i haven't done nothing with the pier
here i have my glamping
corner this is where where they come in
camp
but i made everything all the birchwood
glamping style very glam-tastic
okay oh you know what now since we're
here let's go inside my house
let's go check out my house so once
again
things are all over the place i'm just
trying to use the things other than this
main living room
for the rest and my bedroom the rest of
the house is really just to use up the
items that i have
because i'm just the storage is limited
so there's limited storage space and oh
and since there's been an update
i have been trying to collect all the
mermaid stuff obviously there's still
more i got to collect but this is all my
mermaid collection
and look how cute this wallpaper is oh
my god i love it look at that when you
turn off the lights it's so
cute and look at that shell lamp just
every single little thing i'm like oh
it's just so
cute i can't take it it's the cutest
okay we're gonna go into the bathroom
now
let's see what's in there because i
really haven't been there in a long time
let's see i forgot oh it looks like this
okay this just looks like a
mess it's just clustered with things i
really have not taken the time to
fully think out and design
every single room of the house or even
just the entire island to be honest with
you i've just created
plots of land and just filled them in
with things you're really limited on
what you can do in this game because
each item that you have you really have
to come across
it you have to either find it like by
shaking a tree or go to the shop and
they only have a limited
limited items every day but yeah so
every single thing i have here
it's either like i bought it or a diy
but i really obtained all these things
oh shout out to my mom too because my
mom
helped me a lot in collecting a lot of
things so it's so cute because we
sign on together and we just we we just
exchanged things
yeah and this is the kitchen uh
like i said i really tried to just use
every single inch of this place
and i think i did a pretty good job
honestly like this kitchen
and the living room and like i said the
bedroom i kind of like
you know what i take it back i think i
did plan out
the designs of places because this this
i'm happy with
i like it it just feels really
really nice i like it anyway let's move
on yeah see it's just so strange like i
don't know what to tell you guys because
it just feels like i'm showing you guys
like my underwear or something by
showing you my island because
it really you can really tell what kind
of person
someone can be just by looking at the
way that they decorate their home
or decorate okay so this this room here
is definitely one of those rooms where
i'm like listen i have a lot of things
and these things can probably go
together so let's get them out of the
storage
and just use the things and i know what
you're thinking i could easily just sell
them and i do i sell a lot of stuff
but this room i'm like well there's just
a lot of like tool stuff
i thought about it too i'm like well you
know what in in real life worlds
if i had my own like decked out
workbench and stuff that would be
so cool like in the garage if we
actually had room
i could buy like a whole bunch of tools
and just create a whole bunch of things
and just be very creative and handy i
know what you're thinking you're
probably asking
me right now in the comments but tiff
how long have you been playing this game
and to be completely honest with you i
do not know because i turn
off that feature where it like you could
see like the hour or like other people
can see your hours and i could probably
look it up right now but i'm i'm
honestly really scared
to look that up because a lot of the
times as you can see right now like i
have
my whole setup up here in the loft area
i'll just leave the tv on and i'll go
and like go eat or i'll go shower or
whatever and i'm leaving the game on
so i don't know if that actually counts
towards how long you've actually been
playing so for that reason i really
don't believe
whatever number it's gonna give me but
the last time i checked which was
quite some time ago was like over like
400 hours or something
yeah i've played a lot okay anyway let's
move on let me go show you my favorite
room of the house which is my bedroom
and that's
upstairs and look at this it's all space
theme isn't this cute and look when i
turn off the lights
it's the cutest thing ever
i love it especially the wallpaper and
the floor
it's just so pretty like sometimes i
come up here
into the bedroom and i'm like man why
can't this be my real life bedroom
because look
there's a flying saucer an alien man
it's just so cute
like and then there's just a floating
asteroid there for no reason
and an astronaut here just chilling i i
don't know if i can actually and
honestly say that this is
me because it's so not me but
i just like it it's just cute okay let's
go to the basement now
in the basement besides that tool room
that you guys just saw the basement is
the other like complete
throwaway kind of room that i'm just
trying to get things out of my storage
and just use the things but here we go
so this is the downstairs i have
collected
all the posters of my previous villagers
how can i see it there we go so you can
see all the posters there
on the wall those are all the people
that or villagers i've lived
in my island it's actually really hard
to see
because there's more over there there we
go i'm moving my actual head
it's so funny because i'm like i can't
see there's two beds here for some
reason
and a toilet there it makes no sense oh
and then i put this fan here because i
like how it makes the leaves
just move and like rustle there's a
little hamster here so i have a little
pet see a little hamster hi
that's what i've done with my house
hope you guys like it let me know what's
your favorite thing about my house
honestly for me it's this living room
because of the mermaid
the mermaid stuff is super cute but then
i also really like my bedroom
i don't know i can't decide okay let's
move on
all right so then when we continue going
counter-clockwise right here
is casey's house look at this
i made his house similar to what he
would like
so he has his director chair he has a
smoker here
with some smoking meats and then there's
like a projector and stuff
let's go inside because i don't remember
what i did and okay so
because of the reason that i'm trying to
collect all the things in this
in this game i started using casey's
account
and created an entire house for him and
stuff because i wanted to use that
the storage in his house also i've been
collecting double the diys and diys are
important to create things and stuff
and because i'm trying to collect all
the diys available in the room i've been
using casey to to
just get twice as many so using casey's
account has been
very successful for me if we go to this
room you'll see
i've been using the rooms in his home to
just drop off
all my extra diys that i have because
i've been
i joined uh i joined this discord where
we just trade things so i've been saving
all these diys for me to trade for other
diys
so here i have a whole bunch of them on
the floor
and then another room is just nothing
but diys and
that's pretty much the whole purpose of
casey's house is just to use
use it for the storage space because he
doesn't actually play so i play as him
like as his character and yeah see i'm
collecting more diys here
yeah i don't know like because of the
fact that i've already
kind of done everything i really wanted
to do to the island i've just kind of
lost interest and then also to point out
i'm leaving because
it's pointless to go to any of the other
rooms because it's completely empty
there's nothing in those rooms yet but
as i play i will be filling it up
and then eventually i'll make it all
pretty and stuff right over here
i have this plot of land to grow
hybrid roses so these black roses here
if i water them with this golden can
i create gold roses and this is how i'm
making my gold roses
but then over here i'm trying to make
different colors because
over here i'm trying to just have
all of the flowers that are available so
i just have this like collection of
different colors
different hybrid flowers that are
available
so as you can see there's a few spots
i'm missing like it's really hard
to get a green mum mum's
flower or the rest of the roses i
haven't really
gotten but yeah that's that's for the
flowers
oh and then also i've determined if i
continue playing this game
i'm going to be using this plot of land
here with the roses
for isaac's house if i decide to do that
but
i don't know it's there in case i i want
to here's another plot of land that i'm
using
to create more hybrid flowers all along
the beach on the side i just put random
stuff it's so cute because i'll catch my
villagers playing with his ukulele all
the time
it's really cute by the way i haven't
shown you guys any outfits so the last
time i
messed with my outfits i decided to do
this which is just all the places i've
been
and i created outfits for
different cities i've visited so this is
my guadalajara outfit
and then i have like a tokyo outfit
isn't that cute look at the back it says
japan
and then there's the portland outfit
i don't know i just felt hipster when i
created this outfit
and then a perry a perry
um and then like a retrofit which is
a city in iceland and kyoto
i have two different cities of japan
here because nintendo is a japanese
company
so they have a lot of japanese outfits
and stuff
this is my marrakesh outfit morocco
and this is my venice california not
venice italy
venice california because this just felt
like this is what
venice people wear that shirt actually
uh nikki
and gina and a few other girlfriends
that we
we all play animal crossing we all got
that got that shirt
so we all match with that meme shirt
anyway
those are the outfits back to this one
because this one's
cute i like it i'm wearing my mermaid
mermaid shoes too
and i like how you could hear the
clacking on the terracotta floor
anyway moving on so right over here is
my orchard
i have all my different kinds of
fruit trees here and then right over
here i have the other fruit trees but
then
for the money trees i thought it would
be kind of cool
and i like i like how it looks to um
just see them all filled with the bells
because i'm like look at this i'm rich
i'm so rich and then there's a tree
growing right here so but once that's
done it'll look like these
and it just looks so dense and it's kind
of annoying to walk through
but i just thought it was really cute
but yeah every time i get in there
because just in case i have visitors
that's why i fence it off because i
don't want people stealing my money
moving up we have a zoo
right over here i made a zoo my mom
helped me out with all these different
bird
bird cages because she had the diy for
the bird cage
and then she just made one in uh for
every color in every color for me so
yeah that's
this is my little zoo it reminds me of
the la zoo so i call it the la zoo in my
brain
and then right over here is like an
amusement
kind of like community center fun times
kind of thing so if you turn these on
see
i like spinning cups i really wanted to
create
a disneyland kind of amusement park but
they didn't really have any other things
that would match so i just
put all these things together look how
cute you
play a little foosball little pinball
some darts there's a street fighter here
yeah oh i really like this look look
look how cute
[Music]
this is so funny because this is okay
this game
is legit like playing house
or playing with dolls like in a
dollhouse and all it is
is just putting things around like a
dollhouse and it's so funny because when
i was a little girl
i thought playing with barbies and dolls
were so
dumb and boring because i'm like i don't
want to use my imagination to make
things like i want like
actual interactive toys and that's the
kind of kid i was
but now as a 30 year old woman i find
great
pleasure and great joy in playing dolls
like playing with dolls pretty much on
this video game because
none of these things actually you can
use like
none of these can you actually do
anything with some of the items that
they have in this game
will have like little interactive type
of features but you can't actually use
the things you know like for example i'm
wearing this little pochette like a
little
purse i can't store things in this purse
it's only for aesthetics it's just
it's just to look cute anyway let's move
on right over here
is where you will see the twin heart
ponds
seeing that two little ponds and the
shape of hearts
and then right over here i have my rock
garden and if you play this game
you know what a pain in the butt it is
to get all six of your island rocks in
one
area there's a lot of mannequins that
were used here
is the tick
see it's all tick and then oh what's
that over there
there's two godzilla's in battle
they are battling it out but yeah
i spilled out tick here and i put a
whole bunch of flowers because i don't
want things to grow here
i actually left this space empty to see
if
lily of the valleys will grow because
the ones that i have in the front
are actually not mine they were given to
me by my mom
because she has a different layout of
her island and i think the way i've
created my island it doesn't allow for
the lily of the valley flowers to grow
so
i left that little patch there to see if
it grows and it still hasn't grown
but i do have a five star island so
whatever
it's honestly so pointless like once i
got five stars
i'm like this is all it takes to get
five stars like they need to make it
more difficult
yeah look they they're fighting
the fire breath and then moving on right
over here i have
just the waterfalls i thought it'd be
cute and pretty just to have a waterfall
right underneath the tick and then right
over here
i have another waterfall and a whole
bunch of flowers because like i said i
don't want
random things popping up and
the reason why i have this is because
there's certain fish that are only
you can only catch if they're on top of
a waterfall like this
that's the only reason why i have this
waterfall but for the most part i try
keeping everything
in one like one level here's another
twin heart ponds thing just to like
make it symmetrical i really liked
everything to be very symmetrical
and then right over here is where all
the villagers live
so oh this is a new one who's this
let's go see because like i said i
haven't been on this
island for a few days so i have no idea
who this is who moved in
oh it's this dude hi groucho
i've been good yeah i invited him
from the campsite i forgot i haven't
seen this his house though
how cute okay bye
i love when i leave someone's like a
villagers home and they go
they always go it's so freaking cute
this game is stupid cute
that's why i've been so addicted to it
because everything's just so tiny and
cute and adorable and i'm just like
stop being so cute so each villager i
really put the time in well besides
these new ones but
i really put the time and effort into
really
curating each villagers outdoor
area because i'm like this just this
feels like this is for them
you know like ken lives here for example
this is very ken this is a ken
look robin is new so
like previously used to be vivian that
lived here
and then this is i think annalise
poppy she's my favorite poppy's freaking
cute look at the inside of her house
i absolutely love her decor especially
her wallpaper
oh she's making something poppy what are
you up to
what are you doing a chic mum
crown i don't have that diy
yay oh she called she called me
it's really funny because you can you
can customize what the villagers
call you and their catchphrases and i
always try to make them
like spanish themed like a lot of see
like
her thing at the end i clicked out of it
really quickly but
her thing at the end yeah way
oh i don't know why i think it's so
funny but yeah look how cute her place
is just the cutest but yeah and then
like i have other villagers that
that go uh oh and that's that's their
catchphrase
it's osea anyway moving on so
right down here i have this little chill
area for this tiny little beach and then
look i freaking love this
so i saw this on reddit someone created
a grass pattern so then they can
lay in the flowers and it looks like
they're just laying inside the
in the flower the bed of flowers it just
looks so peaceful
so i really like hanging there sometimes
right over here we have the lighthouse
just lots of flowers everywhere that's
why honestly that's why my
my island's a five-star because i've
just filled it with flowers
but here is the zen garden area
in like asian themed area like i said
you're just really limited with the
items that you
obtain so i'm like i have a lot of asian
stuff so i'm gonna make like an asian
area so that's my zen garden
and then right here is another waterfall
thing and i put these pine trees up here
because
during christmas time they decorate them
with christmas
lights and so i'm just really looking
forward to christmas time and see what
what this is going to look like because
right here is resident services
and if you move down here look at this i
have a wedding
themed cake shop so
recently i think it was june there was
like this wedding event
and you could just collect a whole bunch
of wedding themed stuff
so i'm like i'm gonna make like a little
wedding themed cake shop
and then right over here is a half
fancy italian restaurant half
like mall food court kind of
restaurant i don't know i was just
putting all the things here i don't know
i was really
really really proud of this pizza shop
because along with the tiki bar
i created this pizza shop and also this
coffee shop
it was one of the very first things i
pieced together but look how cute it's
called
star barks coffee not starbucks
starbursts
i don't know it's the simple things i
that i appreciate
that keep me entertained and then look
at pinkie she's working out and so is
frigga you know what every time i see my
villagers working out because they work
out
quite often i sometimes like stand up
and i start doing some squats because
i'm like oh yeah that's right i've been
sitting
sitting for far too long so i appreciate
that nintendo thank you for the
these physical activity reminders so
right over here is my diner
and i absolutely love my diner
i i love it my mom helped me out with
collecting the different
gas stations and some of these like
the pink tables and stuff and i'm sure
you guys have noticed by now but i
love playing with different designs for
the floor patterns
because to me just having grass or or
whatever it is is just so boring so
i just picked up a whole bunch of these
designs on reddit
so thanks to reddit i don't have boring
floors
but you know what though because of the
fact that i have so many different floor
designs it does
it did make my game a little glitchy so
i don't know if you guys can tell it is
kind of glitchy right now
but anyway here is my school i
had so many school themed items that i'm
like well i might as well make a school
and here's where the teacher sits and
then right over here is where the t
the teacher's assistant the ta sits
and then there's only three students so
everyone
has really good great pre-covered times
where you could actually
set foot into a classroom but it is
outdoors
so maybe that might be okay moving on
okay now this this is this is really
what's making the game the glitchiest
which is the gym floor that i have ever
since i installed this gym floor
it's been super glitchy over here but
yeah i have
i have my my whole oops
i have my whole gang uh gym set up
i have a little ball honestly playing
with this stuff is so
fun like look at this just i can
actually just work out like
my little game character gets to work
out and there's a little exercise ball
look at this treadmill see this is the
most you can really do with this game
it's just playing with the things like
this
and that's it but it's just so
entertaining i don't know why and then
look how cute i could actually get on
this
this uh i only did half of of the ring
thing because doing the full thing would
just take up way too much space
so i'm like oh it could just be like
like the corner like they're they're
training
on the corner i don't know why but yeah
that's what i came up with there
and then if we move down here oh wait i
almost forgot this little part
right here i have a little fruit stand
oh wait ken is confused about something
what's up ken do you need me what's up
what's next what are you doing are you
gonna leave me
apparently i bought oh that's it see
animal crossing does this all the time
i'm like are you gonna leave
and it turns out that they just want me
to buy something from them no thank you
okay i gotta go thanks anyways ken
but they're always just so concerned and
i'm always like are you gonna are you
planning on leaving
and they're like oh i actually just want
to give you something i'm like oh why'd
you give me that heart attack
but yeah look this is where i created a
little fruit stand area
so eventually i'm going to collect all
these boxes because there is a pear box
you see i have an apple box but then
i'm going to get a pair of peach an
orange and a cherry box and i just have
to come across those things
so i use this little section here to
just breathe more flowers too
to have to water so here's my umbrella
collection
and i have a few umbrellas laid out in
the other parts of the island but
these are the umbrellas i haven't
figured out how to use them
i don't know how to display them better
because right here just looks like a
yard sale
i would like to come up with a different
way on how to
display the the umbrellas because look
how cute there's a pear
and a i mean what this is a panda and a
bear
panda and bear together equals pear
right here is
the museum and right to the right
of the museum i have a little museum
hangout spot which
right there you can see my great white
shark um
model which is really small small
compared to what the actual great white
looks like
i have a wall of jellyfish back there
because i thought it just looks so cool
especially at night because each tank is
lit up so it looks really nice right
next to nook's cranny i have a little
like liquor store hangout spot with a
telephone thing
and then the snack machine and a drink
machine
and a gumball machine and a look
a little tiny library right here there's
a tiny library
it's right there so cute but
yeah i think that covers the whole
island this
is what i have accomplished to date it
is
not done it's probably never gonna be
done because even right now i'm showing
you guys
i'm like oh but it's not done it's not
ready oh what's up angus is calling me
you're calling me mama
what burns your bee beans oh
i'm getting a new reaction see i get to
collect all the
reactions worry worries one of them that
i don't have
now i get to have worry yay
i learned a new reaction
reactions are the cutest look i have
laughter
i have love and then right here you can
see all of them
i don't i only need one more reaction
left
and then i have them all as you guys can
see there is
no theme to my island at all
whatsoever i've just been using the
things that i come across
oh i already have a utility scene anyway
i am so distracted by this game let me
just
get right here and then stop and then
talk to you okay
thank you guys for watching my animal
crossing island tour
so there's this new feature on in the
game where now you can
visit your dream islands which by the
way i'm sure you guys caught this
earlier but if you play animal crossing
that's my dream address at the bottom
right there so you could come and check
out
my island for yourself since that
feature has
has been a thing i've been looking up
random people's islands and i've been
seeing what they've been doing with
their islands and i'm like oh my gosh my
island is so
boring and so basic and so plain
compared to other people's and you know
what leave
in the comments your dream address i
want to go visit you guys and go see
what you guys have been doing
it's kind of a nice thing to have like a
community and just get to see
like get to explore other people's ideas
too so please
leave your dream address in the comments
below let me know what you guys think
about my island and i'll check you guys
out on the next one
you know what i was thinking too is
doing a video where i get to visit my
mom's island
and then you guys can see what she's
been up to too and then we can like
interact with each other because it's my
favorite thing ever to play
this game with my mom it's been really
sweet we've been bonding a lot through
this game
so it's been great thanks for watching
guys see ya
[Music]
hmm